le droit à la sécurité figurent parmi
les priorités réaffirmée par le premier
ministre et plusieurs fois répété par le
président de république dans les
différentes cérémonies de voeux actuelle
et les chiffres de la délinquance en
hausse sur les onze premiers mois de
l'année 98 sont venus confirmer le
sentiment général qu'il était urgent
d'améliorer la lutte contre l'insécurité
et la délinquance avec un soin
particulier concernant les actes de
violences commis par les mineurs
commentaires olivier-carol la sécurité
priorité du gouvernement lionel jospin
l'a réaffirmé aujourd'hui 2,7 pour cent
de crimes et délits en plus de janvier à
novembre 98 et une fois sur cinq un
auteur âgé de moins de 18 ans les
chiffres sont mauvais jean pierre
chevènement relance le débat j'ai dit
qu'il fallait se donner les moyens
d'éloigner un certain nombre de jeunes
multirécidivistes qui ont 40 réfraction
à leur actif et avant saison et on ne
peut rien contre eux aujourd'hui il faut
se donner les moyens de les éloigner des
quartiers qu'ils ont mis en coupe réglée
je crois que ça fait partie de leur
contrée très bon week-end des banlieues
à bobigny dans l'un des plus importants
tribunaux pour enfants de france on ne
se dit pas si désarmés que cela on me
dit qu'on n'a aucun moyen l'égard de ces
jeunes ils se trompent
vous savez qu'on peut condamner un jeune
qui a plus de 13 ans et on ne manque pas
de condamner des jeunes qui en 13 14 15
ans pour les faits délictueux ou
criminels qu'ils ont pu commettre et
bien pas seulement criminelle
deuxièmement c'est vrai qu'on peut pas
les incarcérer titre provisoire là si on
pouvait au moins les mettre sous
contrôle judiciaire
et si le comte roger tirs étaient violés
être sanctionné ça serait une bonne
avancée il y a un an et demi jean pierre
chevènement suggéré lui la réouverture
des maisons de redressement
elisabeth guigou s'y était opposé
enfermement ou éducation à bobigny on a
choisi sur la base d'expériences pilotes
expérience démontre que par les mesures
qui sont prises par la remobilisation
parental par les dispositions de son
cousin des billets à victime exerçait de
mesures de réparation être heureux
scolarisés on n'a pas plus de 7 pour son
dressing
une méthode qui réclame d'importants
moyens financiers et humains
plus modestement le gouvernement
pourrait envisager une réforme de
l'ordonnancé de 45 sur les mineurs un
texte déjà modifié plus de 20 fois en un
demi siècle